A scream like 7 It
's time to leave [music] Hmm, it's going to
disappear
This place is by the mountains
I
didn't know it was so cold outside the castle back then
[music]
[applause]
me
[music]
[Applause]
car
[music]
[applause]
me
[music
] And
let's carry out our activities.
I'm a princess of
a small country who's been caught in the front row sandwiched between the
mighty me in this year's practice video
.
My daughter will soon turn
16. Hopefully, thanks to the protection of the ancient dragon king, everyone's
hey love will continue at any club
.
Hey, where are you going to send that chintz?
No, it's not a
dog, it's a soul Jonah's beauty is four
ships like that I have a feeling I was born pretty cute
[Music
] Who would say that Princess Edaka's behavior
is strange?
One of the generals,
Haze's tribe If it's a voice that doesn't fear fear,
it's
even cuter.
But why is it that
Saro Maiden is coming right now?
You're as energetic as ever, are
n't
you Princess
? What's
wrong?  You can stay for a while, of
course, because you're here for your birthday, like a week
from
now
.
Children are passionate about using children
From this morning, I applied the finest beauty
essence and makeup, but it's a waste of
money.
I heard
Phil 8, don't worry se
[music] It
's
okay if you do it like this, you can't be seen by others
Hey, it's okay to cry me
2nd place,
ana
[Music]
That's right,
I'll be Yona's mother.
If it spills, I'll wipe it up so no one can see it
So
ahhh tomorrow Akaneko I can't sleep because the noise is so loud
You're my special day
[music]
osu Synchronization
together
If it's Akane-sama, what's wrong
with General
Haku?  2
oz.
It's
okay,
you like horses, right?
Nana, Anatida, and
I, too, are
kind of disgusting. It's
true that there are several marriage
proposals, but it's
not like they
've decided yet.  It can't be helped if I say it again, and
I'm treated like a child.
You
're the
only one who knows the man who's close to white, so don't
look at him with suspicious eyes.
More
hero
ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah, it's terrible to believe a lie It
's just you and it's
annoying  No
,
princess, I don't want my father, Ume, to talk about my love affairs
.
But no matter how much you want it, I
can't give you a phone call.
You must be blood type o,
but I'm the king and I'll choose the successor
.
's mother was attacked and killed by
thieves This kind of danger besets Ohno's bandits
That's why I didn't feel like marrying my wife again I
don't want Tsong to be happy I don't
know I don't know  Underground '
Cause then my husband can be unhappy
I can't be
happy But it's a show
Sean and I hm
someone
vomits right?
There
's
no one there, so I'm running
away If you're a
white guard, you're the one who normally calls
out to me.
I really can't stand death
Why is it that even you are in danger once you're with
me?  I'll send you to the shop Because now you're an
actor, right?
It's okay
[music] It
looks like the rain is a little bit lighter I
ignored it I'll
take you to your room Let's get an escort
scarf  I think it's just the flow If it
wasn't for the misunderstanding Ah, if it wasn't for the
misunderstanding Showa-ya
I
'm in
trouble because you
look like a 92 woman I'm in trouble
Huh
Huh Air hate
Scene like a little sister
Unspecified about hands
Sean Nakata It's a
lie, Enron said that I have that kind of story So
now I'm still
small
I look like a woman At
least
I hold hands and sleep together I
can't do anything I can't do anything I'm
nervous and clear  Put it
away
Well, it's okay If
sex makes me feel a little bit better, that's
all I need right now I'm really in love
with it I still don't know about the country and the secretariat I
'm the best just with him  I'm happy
5 days later I'll be 16 at Iryuujo A
party was held to celebrate my birthday Elle-sama on the stage Mellow
congratulations 16 Hey, hey, father, you can braid your hair after all, I wanted to tell you today, but
I can't.  That's why it should
n't be a highlight Then
Aeon Naha
[music]
Wow,
if you don't mind,
thank you water
Now, please give me an example of something.
It doesn't look
good with
my hair.It doesn't suit
me at all.
[Music]
I like it
Yoda no Kami is a
beautiful Magu
, the color of the dawn sky.
[music] bn
me
His Majesty was looking for me.
I told him that 4 was resting in his room
.
I won't stop using honorifics
It's okay to call me Suwon like I used
to, but I know my status,
so don't you feel something more than that?
I said that too, but it
might be better to keep an eye on the people who come and go today, okay?
No matter
how much you wish, I can't give you a zone with the sound of my hair.
Oh
yeah Oh come to think of it, why isn't there a single guard?
I didn't see one until I came here
.
I can't open it around the time I was
there It's a quiet wavelength for baseball
Thank you for
your
hard work
Soo-won is with the
princess So next time the princess's heart will soon come
It's okay for those two, but I want them to be
happy
carme
anacar
can you
do n
hahahahahaa
What the hell is this?
me
[music]
[applause]
ni
[music]
7 minutes
How was I reflected in
your
eyes?
Talk 4